Our universe is a constant exchange of energy
without us our universe will fall into darkness
all life will die every step you
took to get here i paved the road you
you just walked down Welcome back everyone this
is my eternals video about kang he who remains
versus the celestials and why he didn't stop the
celestials the true history of the main mcu marvel
universe and not the lies arishem the judge told
everyone and how that connects with what's going
on with the kang multiverse war really big cosmic
concepts so if you're new to the channel i do
marvel videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything but during the eternals movie
they revealed the celestials as the true apex
predators of the main mcu universe even though
king or he who remains however you want
to think about him has been controlling
all of the timeline from beginning to end pulling
everyone's strings both ground level humans cosmic
beings alike as if they're his own personal toys
marching to the beat of his drum lest they all
be deleted from existence by the tva during
the movie we learn a lot of the history of
the universe that the eternals thought to be true
was just a lie told to them by arishem the judge
and even after sersi learns the truth about their
existence and the emergence with tiamat on earth
she doesn't learn the entire truth like ayrshim
tells her this big story about the history of
creation but even that story is not a hundred
percent true so if he's been lying to all the
different groups of eternals around the universe
this whole time for millions and billions of years
why didn't he who remains step in to make
adjustments to the celestials why did he just let
them continue doing what they've been doing this
whole time lying to everyone and using all these
lesser life forms like humans and other planets
like cattle to grow more celestials because he who
remains started out as nathaniel richards just a
normal person living on a future version of earth
and the answer is actually similar to the question
of why didn't kang stop thanos from snapping half
of all life in the universe why didn't the tva
arrest the avengers if they were manipulating
the timeline so much with the infinity stones
in the quantum realm it's partially because the
celestials do serve an important cosmic purpose
they're not lying about that part of their mission
even if harrison the judge is lying about exactly
what they're doing and why they're doing it and
lying about his own origins to boot what he tells
sersi is that he predates the big bang he was
created in the void of chaos that existed before
the universe formed like he claims that he created
the very first sun in the very first galaxy during
the loki series if you're looking at the main mcu
timeline here like at the beginning of the episode
the sacred timeline this point here we see a speed
run version of the timeline from start to finish
like it zooms out as the universe expands after a
big bang then you see the universe contract again
and go through another big bang cycle arishem
the judge is claiming that he comes from this
brief period between big bang cycles where all
of reality is just black nothingness there's no
multiverse nothing in existence but the dark elves
we know also come from this point in history from
the thor movies there are also other beings like
galactus who pre-date the current mcu universe he
was like another version of he who remains type
of character he was a scientist who just lived at
the very end of his universe's timeline and wound
up surviving through another big bang cycle my
early theory is that we actually see his spaceship
at the end of his timeline during the loki series
in this intro here like you see the spaceship
come towards frame nobody was sure quite what it
was i think it belongs to galen of ta and he's
witnessing the end of his universe because we're
witnessing a big bang cycle and that's basically a
version of his comic book origin so when airship
the judge is telling sersi about his backstory
he's lying by omission like there's a lot of other
stuff that he's leaving out here from his creation
he's not telling her about the dark elves the
other creatures that existed with him in this void
of chaos before the big bang and he's also not
telling her about the cosmic being that created
him eternity which is the living embodiment of the
universe eternity really doesn't get involved in
the day-to-day affairs of lower life forms like
humans or even the gods like thor odin hella
eternity doesn't even get involved with beings
like king the conqueror in all his variants when
they go around during the kang multiverse war
destroying entire timelines entire universes
but here's where you start to see the cracks
in airshown the judge's story because eternity
is supposed to be born with the big bang so each
universe is born with a big bang eternity is the
living embodiment of the universe so its birth
is the big bang and its first act is to create
the celestials and task them with the mission that
irsham the judge explains to sersi so ayrshim is
not lying about their purpose of creating new
sons new galaxies to help the universe grow and
continue existing because when the universe dies
its eventual heat death it means eternity would
die too so eternity isn't some benevolent god
it created the celestials to effectively help
it live longer it's an act of self-preservation
so the joke here is that the celestials lied to
the eternals about their true purpose but arishem
the judge and the other celestials were also kind
of lied to by eternity during the movie they
make this metaphor about apex predators and at
first sersi is referring to the deviants in the
eternals like she thinks of them the eternals as
the true apex predators on the planet but the
movie reveals that the celestials are like the
actual apex predators of the universe because
we're all just their food source but zoom out
one more step and you realize the joke is
the celestials are just slaves to eternity
in eternity is the true apex predator here issue
that eternity doesn't really care what happens
as long as the celestials just keep doing what
they're supposed to be doing creating new galaxies
bringing it back around to kang the conqueror and
all of his variants though like he who remains
if they're meant to be so powerful that they can
control all the timelines in all their universes
with surgical precision they're far more of a
threat than the celestials so why then did he
who remains not intervene with the celestials
the real reason is because he who remains
needs the celestials to help the universe continue
expanding growing with more life because if they
don't do that in the past like at the dawn of the
universe the celestials won't wind up eventually
sending eternals to earth who then won't wind up
influencing the evolution of humanity the way they
did during this movie and further forward into
the distant future eventually he who remains would
not be born and become who he's meant to be so he
needs the celestials to do everything that they've
been doing so that he can become who he's meant
to be and eventually win the kang multiverse war
so that's why he doesn't care about the celestials
wiping out entire planets that whole conversation
they have in the loki finale where he says you
came to kill the devil but i keep you safe you
think i'm bad wait till you meet my variants if
you think i'm evil just wait until you meet my
variants so the tldr is that if they got rid of
the celestials before he was born it would mean
the end of all reality in the main mcu universe
because he wouldn't be able to win the kang
multiverse war it's very similar to the reason why
he who remains didn't stop thanos from snapping
half of all life in the reason why he didn't
have the tva arrest the avengers during endgame
because he needed the timeline to play out in a
very specific way and a lot of these cataclysmic
events had to happen so that he could eventually
be born and become he who remains but here's the
thing as bad as the celestials seem when loki
and silvi visit his citadel at the end of time
the literal endpoint of the main mcu timeline the
sacred timeline however you want to think about it
just before everything restarts with another big
bang cycle like the timeline starts over again
in this space he is literally the last remaining
living being that's why he's called he who remains
he's the only one who remains at this point in the
timeline there are no more celestials no gods no
other cosmic beings like galactus so eventually
the celestials will be killed off and remember
aeroshim tells sersi that if they stopped what
they were doing creating new celestials cold
turkey right now the universe would begin slowly
dying its heat death but anyone who paid attention
in grade school science would know the earth's
sun has about 10 billion years before it dies
so the soul galaxy alone like the main mcu galaxy
that we spend most of our time in with all the
main characters has 10 billion years before it
theoretically dies good long while we got a hot
minute before they're gonna turn the lights off so
really are the celestials that necessary i think
only in so much as they're useful to the cosmic
being eternity in helping it stay alive longer by
creating more galaxies they don't get into this
idea during the movie but the idea is that the
larger the universe grows the more life the more
powerful eternity becomes so you could also argue
eternity only created the celestials to help keep
it in power or make it more powerful the only real
threat to eternity its only real natural predator
would be like the other cosmos who came before or
potentially alternate universe eternities there
was a plot like that in the comics a while ago
where the first version of the universe the first
timeline the first cosmos comes back as a villain
in chains eternity up if it wasn't clear the
cosmos or like the boss level upgrade to eternity
the living embodiment of the entire multiverse
whereas eternity is just the living embodiment
of a single universe they did introduce the
concept of the eternity character during
guardians of the galaxy 2 when ego the living
planet is explaining his backstory to peter quill
what was happening in that scene as he was sort of
opening his mind in a celestial cosmic way so he
was briefly able to perceive the entire universe
the totality of all existence in the universe
i know there are also a lot of questions about
ego the living planet because he calls himself
a celestial but he doesn't look anything like the
other celestials you have to think of him like a
rogue celestial who's on a perverse mission of
what the celestials are normally supposed to be
doing arishem the judge sends celestial seeds
out to planets to grow more celestials make
more of them ego the living planet was kind of
doing a version of that but he was just trying
to create more of himself using his seeds maybe
they'll cover some more of that mythology when
they bring the eternals characters back either
in a sequel or in other space-based cosmic movies
there was a lot of stuff that they did not explain
during the first eternals movie so i think they're
just leaving that for future movies to cover but
hopefully that explains why kang or he who remains
any version of kang needs the celestials not
because he likes them or enjoys what they're doing
but because without them he would not come into
existence if you have any of the big questions
about marvel cosmic history just write them below
in the comments and i'll try to add them to my
future videos there's a bunch of really big stuff
coming up we're going to get moon night episodes
really soon too i'll be doing videos for all those
episodes click here for that brand new marvel moon
night trailer video and click here for my eternals
deleted scene with kit harington's black knight
character thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!